right
i'm very pleased to introduce uh today's
speaker
um dr pardikarius he
is an assistant professor in the
department of mechanical engineering and
applied mechanics at university of
pennsylvania
he received his phd in applied
mathematics at
brown university in 2015 working
under the supervision of dr ka
kanya dakis and prior to joining
upan in 2018 um
paris was a postdoctoral researcher at
mechanical department mechanical
engineering department at
mit working on physics informed
machine learning and design organization
under uncertainty
this work spans a wide range of areas
including the computational science and
engineering with a
particular focus on the analysis and
design of complex
physical and biological systems you will
see
some of those in today's talk i'm sure
and finally he
is a recipient of a
very prestigious career awards from doe
and air force and
so we are expecting great talk today
with no further ado here
we go uh tucker park podiakis
it's all yours uh make sure you unmute
yourself yeah
yeah thank you very much yangchu for the
satisfaction and also for
having me here today with you i'm
excited to
connect with you and present some recent
work um
so to the audience as young just said
please use the chat i'll try to check
that sporadically but also feel free to
unmute your microphones and interrupt me
if you have any questions at any point
today's talk will be more focused on
methods
and i'd like to discuss some recent work
we've done
in this in the context of what we call
physics and form neural networks which
essentially is a class of
methods um a class of deep learning
methods that we're trying to apply for
simulating physical systems
uh involving partial differential
equations both for
forward simulations but also for solving
english problems
um today will not be much focused on
success stories but more on
open challenges and open questions that
we're trying to understand and address
to a better understanding of how these
constrained deep learning models behave
uh when we're trying to train them and
fit them to a particular problem
so let me start with some motivation and
everything that i will
share today falls under this umbrella of
how do we use machine learning for
physics for
simulating or studying physical systems
or vice versa how do we
use physics to sort of inform our
learning algorithm
and let me start by an example that that
was a very recent
darpa project that ended a few months
ago
so there was a darpa program called the
physics of ai
and essentially there were two different
schools of thought that emerged that of
this program the main idea here is how
do we bake in physical laws
into machine learning pipelines or
machine learning algorithms
and there's two schools of fault here
basically so one is that we want to
basically design architectures from the
bottom up
so carefully sit down and design
specialized architectures that have very
strong inductive biases
in the sense that they implicitly
satisfy the principles
we want to to encoding them so for
instance
they can implicitly be invariant to
simple group symmetries of the
underlying system
so a great example as you all know that
falls under this category is
convolutional neural networks that are
designed to respect certain symmetries
that are
focused on natural images but if there's
other works
uh for instance i'm showing you a figure
from a worker with condor who has
spent a lot of time thinking how to
encode certain
um in various properties like in various
super mutations and rotations for
studying many body and molecular systems
so the goal there is basically to to
train neural networks to predict
uh properties of a molecule given the
configuration of it of its atoms and
obviously the you know the property
should not change if you rotate the
molecule in certain way or
it shouldn't remain invariant under
certain permutations
so the great thing about the first rule
of thought is that
the physics can be implicitly encoded
and it's implicitly satisfied
by the network with no approximation
however you really have to design those
models from the ground up that means you
cannot really borrow
you know fire up your tensorflow or
pytorch
library and then borrow existing
building blocks you have to really
take a step back and code you those
architectures maybe you have to write
your own kuda kernels for scaling them
to gpus and so forth
so that that is the price you need to
pay
now the second school of thought and
this is where this talk will be more
focused on is kind of like the easy way
out in the sense that
we are working with conventional network
architectures
so we'll be using neural networks to
represent the solution to
our differential equations um typically
fully connected or convolutional
networks so
we will have fairly weak inductive
biases and then we'll try to encode the
physics
during the training of the network using
some certain
penalty functions or regularizers in in
our training objective
okay so uh this is not a really
new idea so the first people who try to
uh take that route in the context of
using neural nets for solving
differential equations
uh goes back to the early 90s so the
work of sikho jose and anger and then
lagarix in 98
and then this whole idea was recently
revived
a few years ago and has sparked great
interest
a lot of people are working on this area
as we speak
basically what was a game changer is
that instead of
using you know manual derivations to
complete derivatives of neural networks
we now use automatic differentiation
pipelines
so let me just give you a little bit
more detail so what
i mean here and essentially introduce to
you what
we call as physics inform neural
networks so basically the idea is that
we have a physical system that we want
to study and that system is governed
typically by a partial differential
equation
that has space and time variables and
now the goal is either to solve that
pde if somebody gives us the precise
equation
or the that would be the forward problem
or the inverse problem
means that we have a collection of
observations
we may or may not fully know the pde and
we want to use those observations to
calibrate uh any unknown terms so
essentially to
calibrate parameters or discover missing
terms or closures and so forth
so that would be the inverse problem but
in both settings can be addressed
under the same framework in which we
will actually employ a neural network
to represent the unknown
dependent variables of the problem which
are here denoted by you
so for instance you know if you're
studying fluids that would be
the velocity field and the pressure of
your fluid system right
so we're trying to model the solution of
the system using a neural network
and basically uh we realized that this
is a differentiable
representation so this is very similar
to what people have been doing a long
time in
numerical analysis where you're choosing
a representation of your unknown
solution
typically as a linear combination of
polynomials or some other bases
well here we're using a neural net which
essentially you could think of it as
an adaptive basis model so
in a fully connected neural net setting
you have the inputs x and t
you push them through the network and
then whatever is at the last hidden
layer of your network
uh can be combined in a linear
combination to give you the output u
and essentially that would be the
adaptive basis in which you represent
the solution
so now as i just mentioned this is a
differentiable representation meaning
that we can take derivatives
of the output of the neural net with
respect to the inputs
here denoted as x and t that stands for
space-time variables
that means that we can compute operators
that form the residual
of rpd or operators that form the
boundary conditions of rpd
so essentially by doing so we can
formulate now a composite loss function
and essentially define if you wish a
multi-task
learning problem in which we're trying
to train the neural network
to achieve different objectives at the
same time so the first objective is to
fit any available data
so we're penalizing the data fit the
second objective is to try to minimize
the residual of our pde so we're trying
to encourage the outputs of our neural
net to approximately satisfy the
differential equation that we know
and finally we're also trying to match
any available boundary or initial
conditions
all at the same time so again this dates
back to the 90s and the
catch back then and that's why i think
this type of framework did not really
take off
was that people had to really sit down
and manually derive
those gradient computations so
you write down the forward pass of your
neural net on the piece of paper and
then you
try to take derivatives and you can see
that for more complex equations
that require complex derivative you know
differentiation operations
or complex neural net architectures this
can quickly become a really really
tedious um
task so essentially what happened a few
years ago when we
started this line of work is that we
started using automatic differentiation
as essentially we realize that this
whole computation defines a
computational graph
and then we can basically use a chain
rule with automatic differentiation
libraries to compute all those gradients
of the output with respect to space or
time coordinates but also the gradients
of course as usual
with respect to the parameters of the
loss function so that we calibrate the
weights and the biases of the model
using gradient descent
so this is a general workflow for this
type of framework of physics and formula
networks we start from
some given pde or maybe which we know up
to some
missing terms or parameters and we
proceed by approximating the solution
using a deep neural network
and that essentially defines a residual
so we can differentiate now this we can
plug in the neural network and the pde
uh compute the necessary derivatives and
that will give us a
residual which i denote here by r of
x and t that also shares you can think
of it as a neural network that shares
the same exact parameters as
u of or f of theta uh that represents a
solution
that now evaluates the residual of your
pd
and now based on that we can construct
this composite loss function
that has the several terms that i just
mentioned for penalizing data fits
if we have observational data minimize
the pde residual and fit any initial
boundary conditions and now this
composite loss function will be then
minimized using typically will be
minimized using
some gradient descent um algorithm or
stochastic gradient descent
for which here all the gradients will be
computed with automatic differentiation
so the
both of the gradients with respect to
the inputs of the neural net
namely space and time coordinates but
also the gradients with respect to the
weight and the biases
of the neural network so that defines a
very very simple workflow and and to
convince you let me just give you a toy
example to see that you can actually
solve pdes in you know 10 lines of
python code basically
so here's a 1d burgers equation it's a
toy problem
in fluid mechanics poor months model for
studying turbulence
and it's a non-linear hyperbolic pde
here it's defined in one space dimension
with some appropriate um uh
initial and boundary conditions and then
basically all it takes
is that we have to define the neural net
the solution as a neural net as you see
here
here i'm using some tensorflow semantics
and then based on that we can compute
the residuals simply by taking the
gradients of
the appropriate terms to form the pde
residual again using some
automatic differentiation and tensorflow
i see a question here so how many passes
do you need to backpropagate to get the
second derivatives
uh essentially let me go back here to
answer that question
to get second derivatives essentially
you just need to construct a larger
computational graph so you
you can compute the udx for instance and
that defines
um a computational graph that is
probably twice the size of the graph
that just evaluates the neural network
and yes the every time you need to you
take a derivative
second order derivative or third order
derivative this computational graph will
keep increasing
so that is one of the potential
computational bottlenecks that high
order
systems with higher order derivatives
cause this exponential blow up
in the computational graph and the
memory required for performing automatic
differentiation
however this is assuming that you're
using standard automatic differentiation
approaches so there's other
more technical approaches to automatic
differentiation that are based on taylor
expansions
that are trying to bring down the
footprint of taking high order
derivatives but
that's sort of like a subtle topic that
i'm not going to get into
details today okay so going back to the
burgers equation
essentially a few lines of python code
can
define the loss function for this
problem and then we can evaluate it and
minimize it
using gradient descent and at the end of
the day what happens
we can get the prediction so basically
what you see here at the top plot
is the predicted solution for this
problem so the horizontal axis is time
coordinates
vertical axis the spatial coordinate and
then the black x's are the data
that you observed and here in this case
the only data that you observed were
data
for the initial condition and the
boundary condition of
the problem and you see that they are
all scattered in space time
so obviously if you were to train a
plane neural network using this data
you wouldn't be able to really
extrapolate away from them and
produce predictions inside the domain
right so that would
that would be you asking too much from
your neural network you're asking to
extrapolate apart from the data that
you've seen
and it would fail however now that we
bring in this physics inform regularizer
if you wish
this is essentially what enables us to
get the predicted solution inside the
domain
as you see here in the middle particular
there's some slices
temporal slices and you can we can
compare the predicted solution versus
the exact solution which is analytically
available for this problem
and you see a very good agreement um
this
shouldn't be too impressive for anyone
however i should point out that this is
a deceptively simple problem
in the sense that if you were trying to
solve the same problem using a classical
numerical method
you'd have to be very very careful about
how you discretize your
your domain in order to capture
accurately
the steep gradients that the solution
develops around uh x equals zero so at
finite time the so
you know we're starting from a smooth
initial condition but um due to the
small value of the viscosity
here this new variable in the burgers
equation which is taken to be 0.01 over
pi
at finite time your solution will
develop these very steep gradients
so however for the neural network this
is not
not a problem it has a capacity of
approximating this kind of irregular
function if you wish
and you know the training for this
simple problem takes very very little
time a few seconds on a gpu
some reasonable prediction error so this
is just a toy introductory
example this is by no means the most
impressive result
uh that one can get so in this i see a
question here we're doing the viscous
problem
the shock problem will blow out the
derivative computation
in fact we can solve the inviscid
burgers equation as well but with some
small modifications in the method but
yeah so this is a viscous burgers
equation with a very small viscosity
but in fact you can actually tackle the
implicit problem as well
using uh these techniques uh so let me
just move forward now
to uh a more uh impressive
case study and actually that was not
performed by my group but uh
this goes back to my advisors group at
brown though it's a paper that they
recently published in science
uh okay let me go back so hopefully you
can see the animation now
uh essentially this showcases the
ability of
of this physics and from neuralness to
also operates in the inverse problem
setting
which is also very interesting so in
this case the
task that they wanted to solve is the
following so
what you see here the animation in the
top left this is just a movie
of some passive scalar quantity that's
advected
uh through the bloodstream uh in
someone's arteries so what you see there
is a cerebral aneurysm so it's just an
artery that has this abnormality in the
arterial wall and basically there's
there's blood flow but we don't really
know what the actual
flow field is but what we have
is some measurements of this passive
scalar quantity so
in panel b there you see the aneurysm
sac
and the measurements correspond to some
special temporal data points that we
have collected
along those slices inside the aneurysm
sac so you see two two
slices uh these are the the locations
where the
data points for the concentration
variable are collected
now the question is if somebody gives
you this special temporal data of the
concentration of the
plastic scaler can you infer what is the
underlying velocity field
and what is the pressure so by the way
there is no information here about
geometry or boundary conditions the only
data
is the measurements of concentration
along those two slices
so the exact location of the arterial
wall is not
known so there's no boundary conditions
that are supplied
and the way this um you know the folks
at brown were able to solve this problem
is by
employing a physical neural network that
takes us into the space and time
coordinates
for this three-dimensional problem and
then outputs
five quantities of interest namely the
concentration variable
the velocity components uv and w and the
pressure
however the velocity and the pressure
here are latent variables they are not
observed no measurements were available
however all of them the concept namely
the concentration
the velocity variables and the pressure
are all correlated to the underlying
physics and
physics is expressed in the form of the
navier-stokes equations for the
incompressible fluid
coupled with the advection equation for
the fatal scalar
so these are the equations you see at
the top right of the slide
and essentially now these are the
equations that can help us formulate
the pbe residual which will give us this
physics regularizer in the loss function
of training our neural net so now if we
train a neural network
in order to fit the concentration
measurements and at the same time
minimize the residual for this pde
system
um if we succeed in doing so then we
will
should be able to predict the underlying
latent variables
for the velocity and the pressure and
this is what you see here
in the d panel and the animation you can
see that indeed
the authors were able to predict
accurately
the underlying velocity and pressure
field and also reconstructing the
streamlines overflow and so forth
uh so that was sort of an impressive
application of this framework
that was published recently on science
however i should mention that everything
here there's a little catch
because everything here was done and the
model was trained on synthetic cfd data
which means that these data are
relatively clean they're not
contaminated by
a noise or error model error
[Music]
it's a little bit more challenging to
employ those methods in realistic
sap iv or 4d flow mri or
reality experimental data that is more
heavily corrupted by noise
anyways so i think this is all i have in
terms of success stories as i said
today's talk will be more focused on the
methods and
trying to understand the training
dynamics and the you know
limitations or open questions related to
these
physics informational networks so let me
just take a step back and and give you
an overview of
what we're doing here again essentially
we're considering physics to be as a
prior
for our deep learning model and we're
defining this composite loss functions
so we're trying to inject the physics
during training of the model using
regularization
oh and the review here is not really
common right in the sense that typically
uh
people when trying neural nets you may
regularize the magnitude of the weights
of those parameters data so you may you
know consider the l1 or the l2 norm of
your weight
however here we're trying to regularize
the output of your neural net which is
sort of a functional constraint
so it's a some sort of unconventional
regularizer in the context of machine
learning
models and despite the success stories
that i just showed you
failure can happen at any time even for
the simplest problems
so here's the satoi example again this
is the hellholtz equation defined in a
two dimensional domain
simple elliptic linear equation nothing
complicated here however if you
choose to represent the solution of this
equation with the physics and phone
neural network and you train it
using the framework i just presented
you it won't be easy to obtain accurate
results so here's this uh illustrate
this example where um a fully connected
network with four
hidden layers gets about 20 percent
relative error is measured in the l21 so
as you see here there's a lot of error
coming from the particles of
the domain that means that the neural
net has a lot of trouble
fitting the boundary conditions for this
problem
um now the question is why does that
happen
where does this those issues originate
and how can we fix them
question here is the regularization
still necessary if we have enough data
well it depends on the problem you're
looking at but if you want to
extrapolate away from your data
then yes you need to have the
regularization such that
you know your extrapolations will be
consistent with the physics and you can
get
accurate extrapolation or in the context
of inverse problems you need to have
a you want to infer unknown parameters
in that setting you also need data
okay so going back now to the question
here what's going wrong
let me just mention again what i just
said that essentially the way we
introduce physics
by means of this unconventional
regularizer
which in many times requires us to
revisit
um standard practices so here for
instance you know we can choose to use
the mean squared error as a loss
function or we can just
use a fully connected network as an
architecture
maybe we normalize our data or not maybe
we use
gradient descent or adam as an optimizer
so all those bullet points
most of the time people are taking take
them for granted and we make choices we
just say okay adam the adam optimizer
works great for deep learning let me
just throw uh it
in my problem however what i'm arguing
here is that for this type of problems
we need to revisit
these standard practices and and ask
ourselves whether they're appropriate or
not
um so as a general statement here is
that despite some empirical success of
these methods
we're really still lacking a rigorous
understanding of when
and why these physics constraints can be
effective
in regularizing deep learning models so
sometimes they work and sometimes that
don't work and we really try to
understand
when and why they don't work so this is
really the focus of
the work that i will present today and
it all started
a few months ago where actually looking
at this exact same benchmark that i'm
showing
we try to do some post-processing to
really understand what's going
wrong with the training dynamics of this
neural network model
and essentially this is just an overview
of the symptoms that we observe
and i think it's kind of educational and
informative
to think of the gradient descent problem
in continuous time so
essentially what you see there at the
top is the gradient flow
system for for our physics and for
neural network essentially when we're
training our model
uh we are basically simulating this
great flow from some initial condition
to a local minimum that corresponds to
some local equilibrium of this ode
system
theta here are the parameters of your
neural networks essentially this is the
equation that governs the evolution of
the network parameters
during training by a grading descent and
essentially gradient descent
all it does is it just corresponds to a
forward euler discretization of this
gradient flow problem
okay so so what is going on with those
constrained objectives that we're
working with
well it turns out that when the solution
the underlying solution to the pde
is complicated so it may exhibit high
frequencies
like in the example that i just showed
you uh back here
so you see here we have a solution with
an isotropy and more frequencies in the
x2 direction than
in the x1 direction or you have a
solution with multi-scale features well
it turns out
that this gradient flow problem becomes
very stiff
so in this control setting you see this
plot on the right for different choices
of some constants in rpd we can actually
show that
the stiffness of the gradient flow is
increased
the way we measure stiffness here is by
looking at the largest eigenvalue of the
hessian
of our neural network so that sort of
gives us an indication of the stiffness
of the problem
and then if you go back to numerical
analysis and ask yourself what happens
when you're discretizing a stipple de
with forward euler
well that imposes a very severe
restriction on the step size you can
take and here that choice
means that we need to choose a really
really really small learning rate and
the answer is indeed if you do
choose a small learning rate you will be
able to solve the problem that i just
showed you
and now however you need to choose a
learning rate in the order of 10 to the
negative 6
that means you may have to wait for a
few days to solve
this toy linear elliptic equation so
that is not a practical solution
so indeed the hypothesis is that
stiffness exists in the gradient flow
dynamics of physics and from neural
networks and now the um
what that does is that uh consequently
this stiffness leads to imbalance
gradients during back propagation so
what you see there in the plot in the
bottom right if you now post process
and kind of try to analyze the training
of your model
and you can try to visualize the
gradient magnitudes or the gradient
distributed distribution of the
gradients
uh during back propagation for the two
different terms in the loss function so
in this case we had a term that is
trying to fit the boundary conditions
for the problem which is denoted here by
lub
and a term that is trying to minimize
the residual you see here that the
gradients corresponding to the boundary
loss
all collapse around zero so that means
that during
training during grading descent the
network cannot really change the
parameters
um its parameters in order to fit the
boundary condition
and consequently it has a lot of trouble
fitting the boundary condition and for
the simple olympic problem if you don't
feel the boundary condition you cannot
hope to get an accurate solution
but again this is just a symptom of the
pathology this is just the
post-processing of
inspecting uh you know the patient died
and now we're kind of postmortem we're
we're saying or
trying to to understand why the patient
died
uh so now the question is what is the
actual disease right
well can we make diagnosis and can we
work on finding a cure to these problems
so the focus of this work that i will
present today
is really on trying to take a step back
and try to analyze and understand
the training dynamics of these
constrained physics informed neural
networks
so to do so we actually
uh let me introduce some key concepts
that we use
first of all we try to come up with a
practical theory for understanding
physics informed neural networks and to
do so we we will explore a connection
between deep neural networks and kernel
regression methods
in fact the well-known result is that a
neural network with one hidden layer
that is infinitely wide so at the at the
in limit of infinitely many neurons uh
that neural network converges to a
gaussian process with a certain kernel
and the same thing holds for deep neural
networks so at the limit of
infinite widths we know that neural
networks converge to a gaussian process
with a certain kernel
so that will from the theory some point
that will help us analyze a few of the
properties
however what is more interesting is that
the evolution of an infinite width
network
during gradient descent so under the
gradient flow dynamics
can also be described by another kernel
which is called the neural tangent
kernel
okay so this is one of the main tools
that we will be using here to analyze
the performance
so again the idea is to understand
how the neural network parameters evolve
and the outputs of the neural network
evolve during gradient descent
and we will do so through the lens of
this ntk
kernel okay so let me just
start by some preliminary theoretical
results that
one can deduce from this analytical
framework
so the first result is we can actually
show that
which kind of confirms our intuition
that physics and from neural networks
converge to gaussian processes at the
infinite width limit
for linear pdes and to see that we you
know you can start from a toy problem
like the 1d poissons equation
in which you can actually write down
your neural net representation
and you can take derivatives of this
analytically to compute
the second derivative that you see there
uxx
and basically we prove the following
theorem that assuming that the
activation function is smooth and it has
a bounded second derivative which is
a standard practice for most deep
learning activation functions
then a fully connected neural network
with one hidden layer at initialization
if you take the limits of infinite width
that converges in distribution to a
gaussian process
for both the function itself and the
second derivative and that gaussian
process has a certain kernel which you
can derive analytically
and now this kernel you see depends on
the second derivative of your activation
function
and so forth so this is sort of just a
consistency result we knew that this
result holds for plane neural networks
and now we show that
it also holds for physics and for neural
networks
under linear pde operators it's not a
practical result
so you you can really deduce anything
about the trainability of the network
from this result
however by induction you can generalize
it to deep
fully connected architectures and any
linear pde operator
and in some sense opens up the path for
performing some approximation theory
studies to to quantify the accuracy
convergence rate
uh by looking at the limiting kernel
that is introduced so essentially at the
infinite width limit
we converse to a kernel method and that
induces a reproducing kernel hilbert
space
so now we can check whether the solution
of rpd lives in that space and then
try to come up with certain theoretical
convergence
rates guarantees
okay so again let me just remind if you
have any questions feel free to
interrupt me but for me i think the
more interesting part is the next part
where we're actually trying to study how
um the network parameters and the
network outputs evolve
under gradient descent so what happens
well you know try to understand the
training dynamics
so to do so with we can start from the
gradient flow so this is essentially
what i showed you earlier
here l is the total loss which includes
the summation of the boundary losses and
residual losses and so forth
so it turns out that starting from this
gradient flow you can derive the
closed form system for the evolution of
the outputs of your neural network
denoted by u and also for the residual
of your pde
and the outputs and the residuals
define an od system that is governed by
the equation you see at the top
where you see the data playing a role on
the right hand side this is the network
evaluated at the boundary points
minus the correct boundary points and
then the residual evaluated at locations
x
r which are the points inside of the
domain where we're trying to penalize
the residual
minus the values for the residual and
then you see a linear operator here
denoted by those four blocks k u u k u r
k
r u and k r r essentially this is what
uh what we refer to as the neural
tangent kernel okay so this is a matrix
that is a
function of time and the individual
blocks essentially are
the correspond to the jacobian of
your neural network outputs with respect
to the parameters of the neural network
so the ud theta
and the lb theta for the residual so you
have four different blocks
you have the boundary term which is kuu
you have the interaction of the boundary
term and the residual which is k u r
and then you have the residual term kr
and that defines a symmetric uh
matrix here so now the question is
can we understand can we analyze this
matrix this
neural tangent operator and
through this analysis shed some light
and understand
uh the training dynamics of our
physics-informed neural network model
so uh the first thing that we did and
it's a quite
interesting result is that one can show
that the evolution of the neural tangent
kernel uh
remains almost constant during gradient
descent and and you can see that again
by starting from a toy problem again
this one the poisson equation you can
write down
this closed form system that governs the
evolution of your neural net and the
residual
in terms of the ntk and
we can actually prove the following
theorem so for a physics and from neural
network again with one hidden layer
at initialization and at the limit of
infinite width
we can show that the ntk of this
physics-informed
neural network model converges in
probability to a deterministic limiting
kernel that we denote here as k
star and more interestingly
for any positive time we can show that
this kernel stays
almost constant during training via
grade in descent
so this kernel does not really change so
you computed that initialization
and that can give you a lot of
information
about your training
by by examining the spectrum the
spectral properties of this ntk kernel
and on the right hand side you just see
some numerical
verification of the theorem you see that
as a network width
is increased we are reporting um
basically
the change in the ntk kernel so the
kernel that iteration and
minus the kernel at initialization this
is just a relative error and you see as
the
width of the network is increased the
this ntk kernel does not change
under gradient descent iterations and
although the theorem was proven
for a one layer deep neural network we
have empirical results that that
also that result also holds for uh
arbitrarily deep neural networks
uh so again the ntk uh operator remains
constant
during gradient descent so
in in practice you can actually verify
that numerically that
in all cases the ntk quickly converges
to some deterministic journal and
remains constant
during training for any architecture and
any pde operator
okay okay so there's a question there
isn't that
one relative error is relatively large
so actually this is uh
point one yeah it's well you
you can see that it remains constant so
as i mentioned here in the bullet point
uh the kernel changes a little bit
initially
during grading descent and then remains
constant so it may not be perfectly
the same kernel as in the initialization
but it just
at some point it stabilizes that it
remains constant throughout the rest of
the gradient descent
iterations as you see for instance down
here
after a few iterations basically you
just reach this flat plateau and the
kernel does not change anymore
for the three hidden layer case for the
one hidden layer case which is where the
theorem holds you can actually see that
the error is zero
even from the very beginning so for the
deeper case there is some trans
transient theory uh
window after which the kernel stabilizes
and remains constant
okay so now the question is okay so that
is one property about the ntk
oh you know it converges to some
limiting kernel that does not change
during gradient descent so what does
that mean
well first of all that means that we
could
view our physics and from neural network
as an equivalent to external regression
problems so we can actually
derive um update rules
or prediction rules and and treat our
model as a kernel regressor
however so as you see here you know
these are the standard prediction
equations
for kernel regression you have your
kernel evaluated at the test locations
and you have the inverse of your kernel
at the training locations times the data
however
this is not practical in the context of
pins
because this k star matrix is not
invertible so from our experience the
ntk
of pins is always degenerate and
therefore we may not be
able to casually perform kernel
regression predictions in practice
and you see here this is the spectrum
the eigenvalue distribution of our ntk
kernel for a simple example
you see um the blue line is the spectrum
of the kernel at initialization and
the dashed line is after 10 000
iterations of grading design you see the
spectrum does not really change
however the kernel is degenerate and you
cannot really invert it
in order to treat your method as a
kernel method
so for that additional regularization is
necessary to
be able to invert this k matrix
okay so but i think for me what is more
interesting
is what comes into the next slide where
we actually
through the lens of the ntk we can show
that these physics and from neural
network models suffer
from what is called spectral bias and
spectral bias is also known to be a
pathology of standard neural networks
and refers to the preferential
um uh the preference of neural networks
to approximating
low frequency functions so by default
neural net networks that are trained by
gradient descent
uh have this tendency of approximating
low frequency functions and have a
really really hard time converging
to approximate high frequency components
and you can actually verify that
through the lens of this ntk theory uh
for the case of pins for instance again
going back with 1d poisson equation you
can write down
the evolution of your model in terms of
its ntk
you can compute the eigen decomposition
of the ntk
and essentially what you can show is the
following points
first of all the eigenvalues of the ntk
will characterize how fast the absolute
training error
will decrease so essentially if you have
large ntk eigenvalues that means that
your model can train
fast and converge you know decrease the
absolute training error fast
what is more important is that the
components of your target function
that correspond to ntk eigenvectors with
large eigenvalues will be learned faster
so let's just pause for a second and
think about it so you have a neural
network
trying to train it on a set of data now
or
your pde and you know you can compute
its ntk at initialization and you know
the ntk does not really change much
during training
so right from the get go you can compute
the spectral properties of your ntk
namely its eigenvalues and eigenvectors
and immediately that will tell you
the preferential directions of your
neural network so you will see from the
shape of the eigenvectors
you will see what kind of functions your
neural network prefers to
to approximate faster and it turns out
that if
these eigenvectors are low frequency and
your target function is high frequency
you will have a really really high time
a hard time
approximating the function so indeed it
turns out that for fully connected
networks the eigenvectors that
correspond to high eigenvalues of the
ntk matrix
generally exhibit low frequencies and
that is related to the spectral bias
problem
so our network has this built-in
preference of approximating low
frequency functions
so in practice if we try to throw
use it in the problem where the function
the underlying function has
high frequencies or multi-scale behavior
it will be almost impossible to
accurately
approximate it unless we train with a
small really small learning rate you
know for a couple of weeks which is not
practical um and the last point here is
that in practice we observe that the
eigenvalues of the ntk for physics and
formula networks
typically decay very very fast so that
means
extremely slow convergence to high
frequency components of the target
function
so essentially there's this topology
that we cannot really use
you know based on this theory we
shouldn't be using uh
pins for approximating high frequency
functions
at least using you know vanilla
multi-layer perceptions
models maybe with a better architecture
we could do better
okay so again what i really like about
this theory is just it gives you this
tool that
from the get-go from initialization you
can actually get a sense of
whether you'll get a reasonable result
or not
and this is not very surprising because
neural networks are known to suffer from
spectral bias what it was surprising in
the context of
physics in front neural networks is the
second result that indicates a
discrepancy of convergence rates
in the loss functions and these
composite loss functions that we use
so first of all we can introduce this
metric which we call the average
convergence rate is quantity c
which is basically just the sum of the
eigenvalues of your sdk
basically the average of your
eigenvalues
which can be easily computed and
we can see now we can compute this c
quantity for the
corresponding blocks in our ntk matrix
remember we had this capital k matrix
that was comprised of blocks k u u
k u r and k r r and now we can compute
the c
quantity for the individual blocks and
what we see here
is a remarkable discrepancy in the
spectrum
of k u u and k r r so for instance you
see here the eigenvalues of k u have
magnitude of 10 to the power 3
the eigenvalues of k are are have
magnitude of 10 to the power five
according to this definition here our
network will have a much
higher preference of minimizing the
residual
for our problem and we have a much
slower convergence rate for the boundary
so in this case we can use this
c metric uh that i just introduced to
kind of
detect even from initialization
which of the terms in the loss function
will dominate
uh in the optimization so in this
particular case you can see that
the residual dominates over the boundary
term
and as a consequence the pde residual
will converge much faster during
gradient descent than fitting the
boundary conditions
and that leads to the failure that i
just showed you that the network cannot
really fit the boundary conditions
properly and you get an inaccurate
uh solution okay see some
activity in the chat i wonder why
convolutional networks do better for
some problems
so in this context convolutional
networks
would work like finite differences so we
will have to discretize
our domain uh treat it as an image in 2d
or you know a regular grid
in this case we sort of eliminate one of
the two terms in our
formulation because we only need to
minimize the residual
we're not approximating special
derivatives with automatic
differentiation
and there's a tendency of convolutional
networks to perform better
however you introduce discretization
error
because essentially convolution
corresponds to a finite different
stencil
so there are some issues related to that
but we can discuss more on that a little
bit later so now based on this result
this sort of motivates that there's
interacting terms in our loss function
and then one term is dominating over the
other
so perhaps we can try to account for
that during training
so in the next slide based on this
findings we propose this adaptive
uh learning rates uh strategy for
balancing the interplay between the
different terms and we do that by trying
to balance the spectrum
of the npk for the residual term versus
the spectrum of the ntk
for the boundary term so we can choose
those constants
at initialization and we can even update
them
you know every couple of steps of our
gradient descent algorithm
and effectively those constants lambda b
and lambda are
you could think of them as changing
adaptively their learning rate
that we're using for fitting the
different terms and so we just introduce
those weights in our loss function
essentially which are chosen adaptively
and they're not
tuned by the user and doing that
actually can lead to significant
uh performance improvements so here's
just an example
an example that tends to be kind of
tricky for this physics and for neural
networks and that's a wave equation
so again it's a relatively simple pde
that
physics and formulas struggle with in
this case we have three terms in the
loss function we need to penalize the
initial condition
we need to analyze the gradient of the
time derivative
of the initial condition and also the
residual of the pde
uh if you were to train a physics inform
neural network to solve this problem you
will get a prediction that looks like
this which is
very very it smooths out everything and
it's very
inaccurate and you can actually do your
post-processing and you
investigate the reason behind failure
for this example
and again you see this remarkable
discrepancy in the magnitude of the
spectra for the boundary term the time
derivative term
and the residual again in this case your
model has a really hard time fitting the
initial condition
for the function uh and and it will fail
the predictions will be not good at all
and then in the next slide you can
actually apply this adaptive
algorithm that i just showed you for
like adaptively uh annealing
uh the learning rate uh those constants
here in this case are set to one but in
the next slide we're updating them using
this update rule
by computing the spectrum of the ndk and
you see that those constants
lambda u e t and r quickly converge
after a few gradient descent iterations
to some plateau
and essentially all what they're trying
to do is to balance the spectrum so you
see here the spectrum
of the three different npk components
uh before the rewaiting with solid lines
and then after the
introduction of these multipliers lambda
you see that
when we introduce the lambdas all those
lines the dashed lines
now are have the same magnitude and that
means that during gradient descent
our network learns at the same rate and
learns how to minimize the three
different terms of the same rate so
no term is dominating over the other
and that's the only trick that comes
into so this is exactly the same model
architecture
everything is the same except for the
fact that we're using this adaptive
weight
now for those of you that are
experts in numerical methods you may
kind of recognize
this as being some sort of explicit
discretization of your gradient flow but
with some sort of adaptive
integrator so some sort of adaptive step
size
and you may also wonder what if we have
the stiffness and stability issues
why don't we use an implicit method for
discretizing the gradient flow
and the answer is we can and that's some
you know we're actually working on it as
we speak and we have some
early promising results and that lends
itself to a whole literature and
optimization for um
that is related to proximal gradient
methods
uh so here's another question gradient
descent is fairly simple what if you use
more sophisticated minimizer like
lbsgs so lbfgs is a quasi-newton method
so it
it utilizes approximations to the
hessian
it turns out that for for neural nets it
does not
perform really really well so in my
experience bfgs performs well
in the really small data regime but
overall it's less robust than
claimed stochastic gradient descent
another comment here is that with lbfgs
we cannot really take uh
mini batches so we cannot perform
stochastic updates
so for a larger problem in 2d or 3d
where you may have a lot of
data points that you need to fit it
quickly becomes
very costly to apply
but yeah lbfgs is also an alternative
for smaller problems
it tends to perform well in many cases
and in many cases it can because of it
because of constructing an approximation
to the hessian you can uh to some extent
regularize these discrepancies we see
between the
uh convergence rates and the different
loss terms
so i'm running a little bit out of time
so let me just conclude here this is
just a sum of contributions for what
i like to call the practical theory for
understanding the training dynamics of
constrained neural networks
because this is not limited to to
physics and from neural networks
essentially any sort of multi-task
learning problem where you have multiple
loss functions being minimized at the
same time
it would exhibit similar behaviors so
i i put the summary there in terms of
future directions
it's really interesting to analyze to
perform similar analysis for inverse
problems like this aneurysm
application i showed you earlier so this
physics and formula networks tend to
perform a lot
better in the inverse problem setting
than a forward problem setting
and in fact we can actually justify why
this is the case
through the lens of this ntk analysis
and more importantly is how we can use
these theoretical
findings to engineer better
architectures that can be more
robust with respect to spectral bias and
this training converges pathologies
so the message is that in general we
should
think about developing more specialized
architectures and more specialized
optimization algorithms for these type
of problems
and we cannot really resort to you know
just employing adam or
some plain neural net architecture and
then hope for the best so
it really pays dividends to
to think a little bit deeper about it
and and and
design appropriate methods in this edit
so all the failure
cases that i showed you personally i
don't think that they reflect
a limitation of the framework is more of
a limitation of our current
understanding of how to properly set up
the problem and properly train these
deep learning models
i see another question what about
plugging everything into something like
um you know a more sophisticated time
integration routine
yes absolutely so that's on one hand
what i mean by adaptive integration and
you can use implicit methods
and and people in the optimization
literature have taken that route and
there's this whole family of proximal
gradient and operators clipping methods
uh so here we just we have barely
scratched the surface
on it and i think that's a definitely a
direction that is worth looking into
um obviously it introduces some
computational bottlenecks and
maybe your training might be a little
bit slower but you can gain a lot in
terms of stability and accuracy
so that's all what i have i had a final
slide just to show you some preliminary
results for the inverse problem
where you see here for the it's
comparing the spectra or the forward and
the inverse problem you see that the
inverse problem is much better
conditions
so all the spectra are much closer and
there is no huge discrepancy between
them
and that sort of indicates that the data
distribution plays a profound role in
this problem so for
the forward problem we only had
observational data for the boundary in
initial conditions
so the data distribution was kind of
degenerate however for the inverse
problem we have data available inside
the domain and that regularizes the
problem a lot
and affects the trainability of our
model so again
we don't have a complete analysis for
inverse problems but
this is just a preliminary snapshot to
show that
through the lens of this ntk analysis
they're much better conditioned
than the forward problems so
thank you again a lot for your time and
i hope we have a few minutes for
discussion